this is every state in the u.s. by
Wendover productions and made possible
by the grade courses plus we'll start
with Alabama the first state
alphabetically Magnolia springs Alabama
is the only town in America to have
their mail delivered by boat
although the longest mail delivery route
in America is in rural Oklahoma where
delivery drivers have to drive a hundred
and eighty seven point six miles each
day to deliver the mail to around two
hundred houses Oklahoma State vegetable
is the watermelon which happens to be a
fruit and Oklahoma is also home to
Kansas the town is a real Kansas or more
specifically at this point is the
geographic center of the contiguous
United States while Kansas is not home
to is Kansas City which
counter-intuitively is in Missouri where
the population center of the u.s. is the
average location of every american
missouri borders eight states and is
therefore tied with tennessee as the
state that borders in most other states
tennessee was a southern state that
seceded from the United States and
joined the Confederacy except for Scott
County which seceded from Tennessee and
formed the unrecognized independent
state Scott County didn't actually
officially rejoin Tennessee until 1986
Tennessee's western border was
originally defined by the course of the
Mississippi River which has since
changed course which has led to all
these enclaves and exclaves of the two
states on the two sides of the river the
Arkansas River a major tributary of the
Mississippi begins all the way in
Colorado where nobody's entirely sure
which mountain is the tallest Mel Elbert
or male massive since their heights are
within 10 feet of each other and people
keep building piles of rocks on the
stomachs to make one mountain taller
than the other Colorado is also home to
America's longest continuous street
Colfax Avenue in Denver at 26 miles long
but the shortest individually named
Street in America is reportedly McKinley
Street in belfontaine Ohio at a mere 28
feet long Ohio's northernmost point is
actually north of Canada's southernmost
point Pelee Island Pelee Island Canada
in fact is farther south than parts of
twenty-seven states including California
which as a state has a higher population
than the
higher country of Canada Los Angeles
California despite being on the Pacific
Ocean is east of six state capitals
including Nevada Nevada has the point in
the entire United States where you're
farthest from a McDonald's only 116
miles although Nevada is not the state
with a few as McDonald's that title goes
to the state with 29 McDonald's North
Dakota which according to some legal
experts wasn't technically a state until
2012 since their Constitution was
missing this sentence which meant it
didn't fulfill the federal requirement
for statehood despite having the fewest
McDonald's North Dakota is not America
at least populated state that's Wyoming
which has two sets of escalators in the
entire state Wyoming is well known for
hosting Yellowstone National Park
although a bit of it spills over into
Idaho though in this section you can get
away with murder you see with the sixth
amendment if you're placed on trial it's
required that you are judged by a jury
of your peers which means individuals
from the same state and federal district
as where the crime was committed
Yellowstone is its own federal district
meaning you need residents from
Yellowstone to be on the jury although
if you were in the Idaho part you need
Yellowstone residents from Idaho to be
on the jury except this fifty square
mile section is entirely uninhabited so
they wouldn't be able to form a jury
which means you'd walk free there's also
one single road connecting the entire
southern section of Idaho to the
northern section Idaho with its fairly
low population as one single telephone
area code for the whole state just like
neighboring Montana Montana is home to
the least busy commercial airport in the
US Dawson Community Airport at 4,000
passengers per year or about 11 per day
Missoula Montana is also home to the
warehouse of dftba where you can buy one
of these a Wendover productions t-shirts
for only $20 the link is in the
description the busiest airport in
America is Atlanta's at 49 million
passengers per year or 135 thousand per
day peachtree a suburb of Atlanta is a
community that has 90 miles of golf cart
specific roads adjacent to its normal
roads
9000 families here have golf carts as
their second cars kids are even
encouraged to drive to school from the
age of 12 in their golf carts Georgia or
more specifically Springer Mountain
Georgia is to start to the 2,200 mile
long Appalachian Trail which is a hiking
trail that terminates all the way up at
Mount Katahdin main main is the only
state in America to only border one
other state and it's also the closest
state to Africa seriously it's closer
than Florida the second closest state to
Africa is Massachusetts or more
specifically Cape Cod Massachusetts
which is technically an island since a
man-made canal separates it from the
mainland Massachusetts is actually
farther from Miami than Panama City is
in Miami is closer to the country
capitals of Nassau Bahamas and Havana
Cuba that its own state capital
Tallahassee Florida has the lowest
highest point of any state three hundred
and twelve feet twenty-three times
slower and South Dakota's highest point
South Dakota is home to the geographic
center of the entire United States if
you include Alaska and Hawaii and it was
a made of state a mere nine days before
Washington which was called Columbia
before it became a state its name was
changed as to not confuse it with the
District of Columbia but obviously that
didn't work out
since DC City ended up being called
Washington Washington place is the
official residence of Hawaii's governor
and Hawaii was given its own unique
currency during World War two that was
it's only legal tender so that in case
the Japanese successfully invaded Hawaii
the federal government could declare all
Hawaii's currency worthless to prevent
the Japanese from using it the closest
state to Hawaii is Alaska whose capital
Juneau has no roads connecting it with
the rest of Alaska or North America
meaning you can't drive in or out Alaska
is also one of the four states that
completely bans outdoor billboards along
with Hawaii Maine and Vermont whose
tallest building is only 11 stories tall
that's the shortest tallest building of
any state the tallest building in the
states is Freedom Tower in New York New
York is home to Ellis Island or at least
part of it their territory is completely
surrounded by New Jersey similar to
Liberty Island home to the Statue of
Liberty which is completely surrounded
by new
waters which means you need to travel
through New Jersey to get from New York
to New York Clinton Road in West Milford
New Jersey has America's longest red
light a full five-minute wait
New Jersey actually goes surprisingly
far south farther south than Kentucky's
northernmost point in its southwest
corner Kentucky has a rather large piece
of territory that's not actually
connected to the rest of Kentucky
Kentucky was the birthplace of Lincoln
who was later elected to the Illinois
House of Representatives and in Illinois
is the original Burger King but it's not
the Burger King or thinking of this
Burger King existed before this perfect
king and therefore sued Burger King when
they came to Illinois for trademark
infringement and won so now no Burger
King is allowed to operate within a 20
mile radius of this original Burger King
Chicago Illinois America's third largest
city is just a tad bit larger than the
fourth largest city Houston Texas and
Texas is so enormous that El Paso Texas
is closer to Los Angeles than it is to
Houston Texas Texas is northernmost
point is also closer to Michigan than it
is to its southernmost point from
Detroit Michigan you actually end up in
Canada if you travel due south and
Michigan is the only state to be made of
two entirely separated sections
Michigan's highway 185 is actually a
bike path making it the only official
highway in America where cars are banned
Michigan's Upper Peninsula is also only
connected by land to Wisconsin which is
home to the Green Bay Packers a team so
popular that the waiting list for season
tickets is 30 years long it's so long
that it's common for parents to put
their kids name on the list as soon as
they're born in Watertown Wisconsin is
Utah Street but the real Utah has a
longest section of Interstate in the US
with no gas stations 106 miles on i-70 I
seventy ends over two thousand miles
away in Baltimore Maryland and the
entire state of Maryland has
euro natural lakes it also has this
Panhandle that reaches a minimum width
of 1.8 miles before expanding back out
to 30 miles width out near West Virginia
which is definitively a southern state
but also has this Panhandle that reaches
as far north as New York City and
Nebraska we know in Nebraska is the only
incorporated municipality in the United
States that has a population of one the
one resident LCI ler is mayor and runs
the library and tavern which is granted
a liquor license every year by LC
herself tortilla Flat Arizona is six
times larger than Manoa since it has six
residents and Arizona also has
one-quarter of the four corners monument
the only point where four states meet in
the US Arizona Utah Colorado and New
Mexico which as a state by law still
recognizes Pluto as a planet
New Mexico is typically the last state
to vote in presidential primaries
whereas Iowa is usually the first Iowa
is the only state in the US whose
eastern and western borders are full
water in this case rivers the eastern
border is a Mississippi River which
happens to be the namesake for
Mississippi the Mississippi River also
flowed backwards for a full 24 hours in
2012 during Hurricane Isaac but the
Mississippi doesn't actually reach the
ocean in Mississippi it does so in
Louisiana home to the longest bridge
over water in the world at 24 miles
that's so long separate eight of those
miles you can't even see land on either
side one of the other longest bridges in
the u.s. is in North Carolina the
Virginia Dare Memorial Bridge which
carries cars out to Kitty Hawk where the
Wright brothers successfully flew a
heavier-than-air aircraft for the first
time in history it was a 12-second 120
foot flight that's shorter than the
wingspan of a Boeing 747
North Carolina's southern neighbor is
South Carolina although South Carolina
isn't all that south since more than
half of it is north of North Carolina's
southernmost point and South Carolina
also has a town called North making it
North South Carolina South Carolina was
the site of the first Civil War battle
and the Civil War ended up having a
total of one battle over in Indiana
where the Indy 500 speedway is which is
so Norma
that you could comfortably fit the
entire country of the Vatican inside it
it can also fit 400,000 people which is
the highest capacity of any sports arena
in the world
Indiana State beverage is water while
Oregon's is milk Portland Oregon is also
home to the world's smallest Park
according to the Guinness World Records
book mill and Park Oregon is also one of
the few states to not have a sales tax
along with New Hampshire the only states
have no law requiring adults to wear
seat belts Connecticut Lake in New
Hampshire is the source of the
Connecticut River which is what
Connecticut this state is named after
Hartford Connecticut Airport at lessons
three million passengers per year is the
smallest airport in the u.s. to have a
direct flight to Europe Delaware on the
other hand certainly doesn't have a
direct flight to Europe since it's the
only state that you can slide in there's
not one commercial flight in or out of
this tiny state it's the second smallest
state behind Rhode Island which is so
small that the entire state grows by
three percent during low tide Rhode
Island's second largest city Warwick
shares its name with Warwick
Pennsylvania and in Pennsylvania is
Centralia where the ground has been on
fire since 1962 due to a coal mine fire
and it's expected to burn for over 200
years
Pennsylvania borders Minnesota well not
really but Pennsylvania Avenue does
intersect Minnesota Avenue in DC and
Minnesota is home to the northernmost
point in the lower 48
you see most of the us-canada border is
defined by the 49th parallel what a
surveying error led to this the couple
hundred residents of this area called
the Northwest angle are completely cut
off from the West and need to pass into
Canada then back into the United States
to go to school also in northern
Minnesota is Virginia the town but
Virginia the state is massive so massive
that Ewing Virginia is closer to eight
other state capitals into its own state
capital Richmond Alexandria Virginia is
actually closer to Toronto Canada than
this Ewing Virginia Virginia also
happens to go farther west than West
Virginia Virginia is also home to this
place the headquarters of the teaching
company who run the grade courses plus
and with that super smooth transition I
do have to thank the great courses plus
for sponsoring this video
the
great courses plus is a subscription
video on-demand learning service where
you can watch top-notch lectures from
experts from Ivy League universities
National Geographic this myth Sounion
The Culinary Institute of America and
more well-known institutions they have a
library of over 7,000 lectures about
pretty much anything and everything you
can learn how to cook how to play chess
become a better photographer pretty much
anything you want to learn they have a
lecture on it I personally really enjoy
the course by national and geographic
called National Geographic polar
explorations which teaches all about the
science history and culture of the polar
regions if you want to learn about this
or any of the hundreds of other topics
they have you can do so for free for a
month by signing up at the great courses
plus comm slash Wendover a clickable
link is also in the description after
that completely free first month plans
start at $14.99 per month
other than that even support window
reproductions at patreon.com slash
Wendover productions follow me on
twitter at Wendover pro watch my last
video on first contact here check out my
fan moderate subreddit here and most of
all subscribe to this channel to receive
all my future videos right when they
come out thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in two weeks for another
Wendover productions video